[Musique]
bon je vous remercie de nous rejoindre
sur tv 78 radio sensations et marmites
fm pour ce débat du second tour des
élections départementales dans le canton
de trappes à l'issue du premier tour de
dimanche dernier c'est le binôme et
divers gauche génération pcf dannemarie
bouquet dali rabais et qui est arrivé en
tête avec à peine 200 voix d'avancé sur
le binôme et l'air sortant adnane capio
et de nicolas dainville les quatre
candidats sont autour de cette table
bonjour à vous et bienvenu merci d'avoir
accepté de participer à ce rendez vous
je rappelle pour ceux qui n'ont pas
spécialement suivi le scrutin dans les
yvelines et que la majorité sortante du
centre droit est arrivé en tête dans 20
des 21 cantons trap est le seul où l'on
retrouve la gauche en première position
le comptant le canton de trappes qui
comprend je le rappelle les communes à
des longs cours de la verrière et donc
également la ville de trappes nous
parlerons dans les prochaines minutes de
vos propositions dans les domaines de
l'action sociale de l'aménagement du
territoire ou encore à 2 l'éducation les
journalistes de radio sensations et de
marmites interviendront également
nicolas kirillovitch et nouradine and y
sont présents bonjour à vous messieurs
bonsoir quelques règles a donné
également le temps de parole est
chronométré et ce sera le binôme nicolas
d'un village capio qui commencera en
premier comme l'a décidé le tirage au
sort qui a été effectué avec les
candidats juste avant le début de cette
émission nouradine de marmiton va
débuter avec vous radio locale donc
diffusée sur le 88,4 depuis trappe vous
ouvrez cette émission vous souhaitiez
évoqué avec les les candidats la
question de l'abstention elle atteint
les 60 14 14% sur ce premier tour sur
l'ensemble du canton
plus de 77% sur sur la ville de trappes
également la parole est à vous bonsoir à
tout les candidats tous les candidats
qu'ils sont sur le plateau
à la première question effectivement
touche à l'abstention pour le canton de
trappes vous l'avez rappelé moules
frites seulement 25 86 % des inscrits se
sont déplacés
ça fait peu sur 33 1500 inscrits ça fait
vingt-quatre mille huit cent trente sept
personnes qui ne sont pas allés voter
et puis si on prend le
mignon qui est un ver en tête donc avec
anne-marie bouquet à lire abc 39 8%
certes du premier c'est du pur pour les
personnes qui sont qui sont ou qui ont
voté mais si on prend ça au niveau de
l'ensemble des inscrits c'est seulement
à peine une personne sur dix qui s'est
déplacé pour aller voter pour les
personnes ans quitte alors la question
c'est jusqu'à quand les élus vont-ils
vont-elles se contenter d'être élu avec
si peu de voix
ils veulent alain villain capio c'est
vous qui débute est donc effectivement
très forte abstention au niveau national
donc malheureusement ce sur tout
vraiment tout le territoire national
on a je dirais une pandémie qui a
beaucoup touché les français on a
aujourd'hui un déconfinement une un
certain vent de liberté donc les
français ont boudé illusion aussi parce
qu'il ya un lassitude de cette période
je pense que le fait aussi d'avoir deux
élections le même jour à complexifier la
compréhension du scrutin et pourtant
c'est une action essentielle le
département la région
c'est les transports c'est les personnes
âgées
c'est la question de l'autonomie c'est
les collèges pour le département c'est
les lycées pour la région donc ce sont
le quotidien c'est le quotidien de nos
concitoyens
et donc c'était important qu'ils
participent pour vraiment se positionner
sur l'ensemble des politiques de nos
deux institutions la région et le
département puisque je rappelle c'est le
même jour donc dimanche prochain
n'aurait-il n'hésitez pas à intervenir
si vous souhaitez relancer reposer
d'autres questions sur ce sujet en
attendant je passe la parole à lire à
bernard ebooks et moi pour ma part
j'estime qu'il faut qu'on arrête de se
voiler la face
en particulier nous les élus locaux et
les élus en général de fait d'élection
en élection les électeurs nous envoie le
même signal ils nous disent qu'ils n'ont
plus confiance en la démocratie qui
n'ont tout simplement plus confiance
dans leurs représentants élus il ne leur
donne de moins en moins de légitimité ce
que j noureddine a livré ça doit nous
interroger et nous en sommes en partie
responsable nos institutions
dysfonctionne et on ne corrige pas ces
dysfonctionnements qu'on les connaît
depuis longtemps et où la parole aussi
des hommes et des femmes politiques est
démonétisé
de plus en plus de concitoyens
considèrent que voter pour un camp pour
l'autre ne changera pas grand chose à
leur vie qu'ils ne sont pas concernés
les jeunes politique aussi et femmes
politiques ont tendance à prendre des
agrumes des engagements il ya les trahir
à dire qu'ils vont faire blanc à faire
noir et compris localement j'interpelle
nicolas dainville zaraï comme il le peut
sur sa ville mais nicolas deauville dont
l'état vient en période électorale qu'on
va pas démolir un quartier qu'on l'écrit
noir sur blanc quand on signe un papier
face à des centaines et des milliers
d'habitants et qu'on fait le contraire
est bien décrite décrédibilise la parole
politique et aux prochaines élections
même les élections nationales on aura
des citoyens qui diront mais ça ne sert
à rien puisque ils mentent tous et cette
idée que tous les politiques mentent
elle est catastrophique alors sur les
rythmes scolaires chez moi j'ai fait le
contraire j'ai une conviction
personnelle que j'ai porté pendant la
campagne j'ai dit que j'étais pour les
quatre jours et demi avec benoît hamon
avec beaucoup d'autres en france avec
vincent peillon avec énormément et des
gens de droite et de gauche d'ailleurs
qui défend des les sacs matinée mais
j'ai donné la parole aux habitants
j'aimais mieux fait mieux que ça je
l'aurais donné l'occasion de voter pour
s'exprimer et ils ont très
majoritairement contredit celui qui
allait devenir le futur maire de trappes
est devenu maire de trappes je me suis
plié aux suffrages des électeurs faut
l'accepter
c'est une proposition que je fais c'est
valable aussi pour un département de
temps en temps il faut qu'on accepte de
céder un peu notre souveraineté dont on
est jaloux quand on a été élu par
seulement un électeur sur dix
potentiellement alors il faut accepter
de donner la parole aux neuf autres y
compris en dehors des élections pour
leur demander sur chaque projet de
donner leur avis sur les grands projets
on va pas demander aux gens de donner
leur avis sur la rénovation d'un
trottoir
mais quand on décide d'un nouvel
équipement de la rénovation d'un
quartier la destruction de barres
d'immeubles
alors on demande aux gens ce qu'ils en
pensent on les écoute pas être en
désaccord à la fin on respecte ce qu'ils
nous disaient ce qu'ils ont à nous dire
il connaît d'un vélo je vous laisse bien
évidemment répondre et puis nos radios
si vous souhaitez revenir sur ce sujet
pour répondre je partage que vous n'êtes
dire c'est dire que il ya peut-être un
ras-le-bol de voir certains élus et là
je vais parler de vous vous avez
notamment été condamné pour un an
d'inéligibilité votre élection annulée
vos comptes de campagne rejetée pour une
violation grave
les règles électorales et vous qu'est ce
c'est vrai que beaucoup de gens aussi
s'interroge sur votre candidature est-ce
que c'est sincère ou est ce que c'est
pour trouver un mandat et un poste et
continuer une tribune politique
donc premier point je partage que vous
venez de dire c'est à dire effectivement
dans le comportement irréprochable dans
l'éthique républicaine c'est vrai que
moi je trouve votre comportement peut
poser aussi des questions auprès de nos
concitoyens sur le même comportement
nicolas votre comportement et le fait
d'avoir été condamné d'accord par le
tribunal administratif en première
instance et le fait de maintenir votre
candidature alors que il y a eu la
condamnation le rejet de vos comptes de
campagne et la tante des juges du
conseil d'état sur le bois de l'étang
c'est un sujet central 1 à l'époque il y
avait un temps glacial a derrière vous
êtes maire je le rappelle aussi pour les
les zodiac à la charte de relogement
c'est un point qui m'a fait beaucoup
évolué sur le sujet la charte de
relogement
c'est vous y avez participé monsieur raz
b puisque vous êtes vous avez voté aussi
cette charte c'est un accord inédit
entre les douze communes et les onze
bailleurs alors là je reprécise parce
qu'effectivement pour clarifier pour les
électeurs à qui nous rejoignent on parle
bien du scrutin départemental est ce à
dire que vous êtes maire nicolas
mainville de la verrière vous êtes vert
à l'érable et de la ville de trappes et
vous évoquez les négociations qui ont
lieu dans le cadre de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines où vous siégez
les uns et les autres voilà gelos rue
lorient peut investir yeux mais je le
rappelle à lire abus vous étiez aussi
présent lors du comité national
d'engagement
vous avez aussi présenter votre projet
je crois qu'après six ans démolition de
prévu 600 démolitions prévues en vous
trompez soleil ce qui est évoqué donc la
verrière a aussi droit comme trappe lui
comme trappe l'a fait avec guy malandain
qui a fait vraiment un travail
exceptionnel soit question de la
rénovation urbaine la verrière a aussi
le droit d'offrir le meilleur pour les
générations futures et pour les
générations présentes et pour terminer
puisque vont interpeller la sur la
verrière ses 130 millions d'euros pour
une nouvelle école pour une nouvelle
maison de quartier pour une nouvelle
entrée de ville le département nous
soutient le préfet nos soutiens
l'ensemble des partenaires nous
soutiennent
et effectivement
il est aussi du devoir des élus de
penser à l'avenir d'accepter parfois de
bousculer les habitudes mais en tout cas
et j'ai énormément d'habitants qui nous
soutiennent sur ce sujet ils sont très
très très nombreux et ils ne veulent pas
être pris en otage par une petite
minorité et souffler sur les braises
divisé jeter d'huile sur le feu
c'est pas une façon de faire je vous le
dis moi je suis pas allé à trappes pour
exciter les uns les autres vous venez
vous êtes venu à la verrière c'est votre
droit pour des fins purement
électoralistes
en tout cas ce n'est pas ma façon de
faire si on veut juste voir les temps de
paroles qui s'affichent vous êtes à 3
minutes 40
capio nicolas dainville et anne marie
bockel irabé à 2 minutes 10 vous avez un
petit peu plus de retard à jeunesse
répondrait et que nour a nié une cuisse
vont revenir avec le puisse repasser la
parole à mon frère me seront évoqués
l'abstention un petit mot rapide parce
que c'est important c'est pas tellement
le contenu du projet du maire de la
verrière que je critique il peut porter
le projet qu'il souhaite après il
consulte les habitants il les associe ou
pas etc
c'est à eux de le juger c'est
effectivement pas au maire de trappes en
revanche ce que je juge
et quand je dis que ça justifie une part
de l'abstention dans notre pays très au
delà des frontières de trades de la
verrière où d'elancourt ces hommes et
ces femmes politiques qui disent une
chose pendant les élections et le
contraire le lendemain des élections
les habitants de la verrière et en
particulier du bois de l'étang
effectivement je suis allé voir et j'ai
entendu dans leur détresse qu'est ce
qu'ils disent ils disent nicolas nicolas
d'une petite minorité ou dix ans qu'ils
disent parce que ça m'a français il les
appelle par votre prénom
nicolas en campagne électorale nous a
dit quelque chose
il a écrit noir sur blanc il a signé de
sa propre main et il a apporté un projet
lakers assez pour dire sur ab nous
pouvons faire un projet sans aucune
démolition tout en construisant une
école mais on peut le freiner
carrasco l'intérêt de m'interrompre
choses et potemkine on peut le faire
mais il veut enfouis dans les vallées
les six nations on peut faire énormément
de choses sans démolir un seul logement
dans le cadre de l'anru et monsieur
dainville élu maire de trappes contredit
nicolas alors élu mais en dix ans et le
pardon énumère de la verrière
contredit nicolas le candidat en disant
exactement l inverse eh bien ça mais
j'ai inscrit la déflation
je respecte le fait qu'il lui avait le
droit d'évoluer évoluer dans compris nos
décisions ayant trait aux périodes
électorales de financer le contraire de
ce qu on pense alors les na'vis au moral
en période électorale les grandes gigues
sur le quartier notamment en rénovation
urbaine je n'ai jamais dit aux habitants
savaient très bien qu'ils vous l'avez
déjà ficelé ok il est déjà un méli ce
qu'ils voulaient entendre
et je vous interromps sur ce sujet et
jeunes rapidement su moi j'ai demandé et
obtenu auprès de l'anru six mois
supplémentaires pour aller au bout de la
concertation si nous voulons que les
gens retrouvent le chemin des urnes
il faut leur demander leur avis les
associés quitte à la fin a assumé de
dire nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
vous mais respectons les écoutons l'est
et prenons le temps les injections
qualité de paradis matthieu rappez c'est
à dire monsieur rabais vous êtes dans
l'attaqué toujours là pour diviser
toujours là pour jeter de l'huile sur le
feu vous demander d'assumer mais je me
débrouille et josé anigo attendent aussi
des propositions concrètes on va parler
des propositions j'aimerais qu'on ait le
temps de le faire au cours de cette
émission donc je vous interromps de tout
de suite parce qu'on a plus de dix
minutes d'émission est effectivement
n'avons pas du coup à avancer même s'il
est important de faire ces précisions au
début nouradine j'en viens vers vous
enfin pour nous oui je pensais pas que
ma première question serait aussi bien
illustré par ce que je viens de voir
pendant 10 minutes
c'est à dire que j'attendais un peu
d'humilité sûr j'espère que les
candidats les candidates ne vont pas se
fâcher lendemain de ma réflexion
j'attendais un peu plus d'humilité
peut-être ce cas tombe peut-être mois
les personnes avec qui j'ai l'occasion
de l'été changé mais vous voyez le début
du débat wilfried l'abstention c'est
peut-être également la qualité du débat
politique du débat public sur les
propositions je ne nie pas que ce qui a
été soulevée par les dieux candidat est
complètement nulle et non avenue
loin de moi cette idée mais quand on
commence un débat en disant bon bon
l'abstention c'est que vous en gros vous
avez dit un truc êtes un menteur
au lieu que vous vous êtes vous êtes
voilà vous êtes inéligible vous allez
perdre la mairie et puis et puis vous ça
que vous habitez ça aux candidats non
pas que
non pas que les arguments sur le fond
n'est pas de fond mais sur la forme en
tout cas telle qu'elle est on assiste à
un combat où les idées ne sortent jamais
vainqueur voilà moi c'est ce que je
voulais dire et est ce que les
candidates et les candidats présents sur
le sur le plateau sont conscients de
l'impact de leurs façons de débattre et
ce sera ma dernière question sur les
françaises et les français les citoyens
et citoyennes qui les regardent et qui
veulent peut être plus le débat apaisé
sur du faux est moins sûr de la querelle
politique
merci noureddine pour votre intervention
and capio je vous passe la parole si on
peut vous pouviez les uns et les autres
est très con sic on avance et qu'on
parle des propositions justement je suis
entièrement d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit là la question était de
savoir ce que l'on pensait nous en tant
que candidat de l'abstention
monsieur rabais vont démarrer au quart
de tour en accusant monsieur d'un bill
sur un projet de sa vie je pense que bon
voilà ça intéresse sans doute vaut vos
partenaires sur la verrière et voilà
mais les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent ne seront intéressés moi je
pense que l'abstention c'est
effectivement nous politique on a une
part de responsabilité parce que on
n'explique peut-être pas suffisamment ce
que l'on fait sur le terrain la crise
commune ne nous a pas aidé et je
m'excuse mais au niveau gouvernemental
n'y a pas eu non plus beaucoup de
communication autour de cette élection
on aurait aimé avoir des petits spots
pour expliquer aux jeunes à quoi sert un
conseiller départemental et ça nous
aurait bien aidé voilà vous l'a fait sur
notre antenne et sur les différentes en
tête de nos partenaires médias qui sont
avec nous d'ailleurs anne marie bockel
vous passe la parole autres médias l'ont
fait aussi moi j'écoute france inter il
ya eu beaucoup de spots et que je
trouvais plutôt intéressante donc je
vais répondre sur une abstention
moi je ne suis pas élu je suis la seule
ici effectivement ça me pose problème
et quand vous avez commencé à répondre
je me suis dit que l'abstention est née
d'un sécateur
vous ne parlez pas aux gens vous ne
parle pas vos électeurs vous ne parlez
pas au citoyen avec lesquels vous
devriez travailler main dans la main et
c'est ce qui me pose problème
comprends mais à quel général voilà
vous m'excuserez vous m'excuserez
m'excuserai s'il vous plaît je sais qui
prend en compte la vide
excusez moi pour m'excuser je vais juste
tempérer essayé de réconcilier tout le
monde j'allais dire qu'on est des
systèmes un mea culpa général éric que
c'était très bien mais visiblement vous
n'avez pas envie
alors on s'arrête là en tout cas merci
nouradine d'avoir participé aussi à ce
débat donc que les auditeurs de marmites
peuvent également suivre nous
poursuivons nous parlons d'éducation à
présent éducation au sens large le
département s'occupe des transports de
la restauration scolaire d'orientation
aussi et puis du numérique des bâtiments
pour ce qui est du bas des bâtiments
justement il ya une question précise que
je vous pose si je vais commencer par
vous ou nicolas david lane capillon il
était question sous la mandature qui
s'achève de démolir peut-être les
collèges courbet et gagarine au profit
d'un seul lieu plus grand et plus
moderne pour 2026 est ce que c'est le
cas alors concernant les collèges alors
le département a un plan financement
ambitieux puisque l'on parle de 72
millions d'euros pour rénover les 116
collège de l'ensemble du département
c'est quand même une prouesse dans un
dans un contexte budgétaire à peu près
apocalyptique ou pas loin suite aux
coupes budgétaires du gouvernement donc
au département les enfants restent notre
priorité
alors à ce sujet effectivement j'ai
rencontré la semaine dernière le
collectif des collège de trappes composé
d'enseignants et de parents d'élèves et
je les ai reçus pour mettre fin à une
rumeur qui court sur la ville de trappes
suite à vos propos monsieur rabais aux
parisiens qui sont intervenus dans les
colonnes du parisien du 24 mai ou voilà
vous laissiez un peu planer de doute là
dessus donc pierre bédier le président
du département vous a fait une lettre
datée de femmes est pour vous dire
clairement que ce projet n'était pas
rebond qui n'était pas question de
démolir un collège pour regrouper deux
autres collèges
à l'intérieur d'un même collège les
trois collèges responsble séparés avec
des rénovations dans chaque collège donc
voilà donc cette rumeur a traîné
j'espère que ça va enfin cesser parce
que voilà le projet et n'est pas celui
ci et on veut garder des collèges à
taille humaine et les rénover chacun
autre précision que je n'ai pas apporté
au début du débat vous faites partie du
binôme sortant vous siéger au sein de la
majorité
je veux le précise ali rabais et
anne-marie bouquet un mois sur ce sujet
chez moi j'ai des choses à dire
effectivement il ya tellement ils
encourent deux collèges qui sont dans un
état piteux celui de la clé prend l'eau
donc régulièrement les élèves ne peuvent
pas rentrer par le hall parce que il ya
une flaque d'eau énorme à qui les
empêche de le faire
ça détruit l'écart d'âge etc bref ça les
fait travailler dans des conditions qui
sont juste incroyables je pensais même
pas que c'était possible et sur le
numérique
je suis parents d'une collégienne qui a
énormément galères et donc mettre des
caméras dans les collèges ça nous a
coûté une fortune et ça ne sert à pas
grand chose quand il n'y a pas d' élèves
dans les collèges par contre ouvrir des
lignes supplémentaires pour que des
enfants est taxé aux ent écrit le
travail dans des conditions correctes ça
me paraît ne me neeman
donc c'est très bien de prôner le
numérique moi je suis pour mais par
contre ce serait bien de faire dans des
meilleures conditions et en tout cas de
permettre aux enfants de réussir une
scolarité ce qu'il souhaitait parler sur
la question des collèges spécifiquement
et sur cette question des halles en
collège et de cette rumeur vous avez
évoqué donc anne capio et puis on
parlera du numérique spécifiquement
juste après alors vous voyez typiquement
c'est une belle illustration notre
premier débat quand les politiques
préparent des projets dans le dos des
habitants
c'est pas une rumeur c'est un projet
écrit d'ailleurs mon prédécesseur avait
donné son accord à la démolition d'un
collège et à maintenir que deux collèges
sur trappe par écrit par courrier que
j'ai retrouvé dans les archives en
arrivant dans son bureau
c'était un projet du département travail
et coûté arrêté de suivre vous plaît
d'interrompre civile son mirador montrer
l'exemple monsieur david montrer
l'exemple
on parle de 10 de montrer aux électeurs
et je demande soit pas décompté de mon
temps de parole s'il vous plaît je vous
arrête la scop
allez-y revenez sur le réseau à vos
propos ne m'interrompez pas comme je
vous écoute patiemment débat donc je
disais ce projet existait il était
planifiée prévu par les services du
département
j'ai été rencontrés moi-même en
septembre dernier le président pierre
bédier pour lui dire je ne permettrai
pas qu'un collège soit démolie et dans
une ville qui en croissance permanente
qu'il faudrait plutôt un quatrième
collège à taille humaine plutôt que deux
collèges de 1000 élèves chacun pire
bédié m'a confirmé à l'époque que
c'était bien les projets du département
m'a indiqué que les chiffres qu'il avait
justifié la destruction de ce collège
je lui ai envoyé un courrier une semaine
après chiffres à l'appui démontrant
depuis cinq ans l'évolution à la hausse
des effectifs et l'absence totale
d'arguments pour démolir un collège à
trappes
aucune réponse depuis le mois de
septembre j'ai du respect pour pierre
bédier d'ailleurs souvent nous
communiquons efficacement mais sur ce
sujet aucune réponse silence radio du
département j'ai effectivement reçu le
collectif courbe est toujours inquiet et
il a raison et il le sera encore plus
après votre rencontre c'est ce qu'ils
m'ont indiqué ils sont toujours
mobilisés sur le pied de guerre parce
qu'ils souhaitent avoir des véritables
garanties qui ne soient pas des
garanties en période électorale
uniquement c'est donc après ma
communication écouter me répéter je te
ramène quand même et c'est ça que je
supporte plus loin en politique
et si je n'étais pas un élu peut-être
que moi même je n'irai plus voter à
cause de ce type de comportement j'ai
écrit en septembre pour demander des
garanties et avancer des chiffres
justifiant le maintien des trois
collèges je n'ai eu une réponse qu'après
la publication de l'article du parisien
courrier qui mentionne cet article du
parisien
enfin de la part de l'exécutif pour me
dire nous acceptons de conserver les
trois collèges
je n'ai aucune garantie à l'heure où je
vous parle aucune sur les rénovations de
ses collèges notamment le niveau des
financements consentis
donc moi je me battrai et le collectif
et les parents et les enseignants ils
vous l'ont dit je me battrai pied à pied
et c'est pour ça aussi que je souhaite
être conseiller départemental avec
anne-marie bouquet on se battra pour que
les collèges de notre canton en
particulier mais partout dans les
yvelines soit rénové convenablement
parce qu'il est épouvantable d'avoir
cours dans les collèges où ils peuvent
les salles de classe
fait trois défaites sont en insécurité
qu'il ya des courants d'air même quand 9
n'était fermée donc c'est épouvantable
et donc on se battra pour rénover ses
collèges convenablement nom en
particulier dans nos ville d'elancourt
de trappes et de la verrière les trois
communes qui composent le canton de
trappes débat qui a lieu ce soir donc
sur les antennes de radio sensations
marmite et tv 78 capio si vous pouviez
répondre sur cette question de des
collèges
vous nous dites que si vous êtes élu si
vous représentez ce canton il n'y aura
pas de destruction que ce soit bien
clair et qu'on passe au sujet du
numérique pendant six ans pendant six
mois alors moi je sais plus quoi dire
chez plus quoi faire je reçois les
enseignants je reçois les parents
d'élèves je fais faire un courrier par
le président du département qui vous
écrit monsieur rababou maire de trappes
est qui et qui vous dit il n'y aura pas
de destruction
donc bon moi je veux bien qu'on débatte
encore pendant toute la nuit sur tout le
monde n'est pas définitif et ferme dans
laquelle ce projet est abonné à
abandonner son projet d'accord je viens
hamad et monsieur rabais ont peu évolué
on peut prévoir des gens cette évolution
monsieur bédié vous a senti le président
vous a écouté a vu la démographie david
et donc a décidé de voilà où on en est
là donc cette question-là n'y en a alors
parlé du numérique la preuve que des
gens n'ont plus confiance on vous parle
on parlera présent de numérique vous
vous demandiez les uns et les autres à
vouloir vous respecter pour pouvoir
échanger je vous mourrez tous les quatre
de respecter cette règle au moins pour
le temps du débat pour amener les
électeurs vers les urnes
ce serait bien m capio sur les questions
du numérique vous avez été interpellé
aussi quel est le plan numérique et quel
projet vous avez si vous êtes réélu pour
ce canton la table alors haut niveau au
niveau des collèges il ya un plan
numérique ambitieux puisque tous les
collèges on est équipé d'outils
numériques tous les collèges ont été ou
sont en train d'être branché à la fibre
optique
il y a un gros plan de développement et
moi je me suis aussi battu avec le
département pour avoir un plan au niveau
local au niveau de saint quentin en
yvelines puisqu'il ya un projet il n'ya
pas c'est pas un projet s'est mis en
route sur le territoire d'équipements
aussi des écoles pour avoir une
continuité pédagogique entre le primaire
et le collège
donc c'est un projet qui est financé à
50% par le département 20 % par la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et le reste à
charge des communes des 30% sont donc
dépensé sous forme de deux 2 2
d'appel à concours de fonds de concours
de fonds concours voilà donc c'est à
c'est un projet qui qui est déjà en
route de toutes les villes ont joué le
jeu
voilà ta relation concernant les écoles
concernant les écoles voilà ils sont le
collège aujourd'hui le plan numérique
fonctionne
ou est ce qu'il y a comme dit anne-marie
bouquet ddd fabrique des choses qui ne
fonctionnent pas aujourd'hui la revoir
on peut toujours trouver un des fenêtres
qui ferme mal d robinet qui fuit la
moquette qui se décolle effectivement
dans les collèges peut y avoir des
problèmes de maintenance sur les 117
collège je t'en sais que quand des
élèves sont obligés de jean gardien
belge entend bien madame à ce qu'elle
fait front madame c'était légitime de
travail allemagne le bouquet en capitaux
je vous laisse répondre
madame poker je ronge et on sent bien
mais on va pas débattre sur la
maintenance des collèges bien sûr qu'il
ya on peut toujours faire mieux on peut
laver plus blanc et je suis au courant
de ses problèmes de maintenance ça peut
ça peut effectivement arriver et et
voilà mais par contre pour le numérique
pour le numérique c'est un projet qui
avance on a actuellement certains
collèges qui se sont lancés dans une
expérimentation d'équipements
individuels des enfants en tablettes
numériques des élèves en tablette
numérique
donc je rappelle que c'est l'équipe en
individuel étaient proposés également
aaa aux villes de la communauté
d'agglomération saint quentin en
yvelines que la ville de trappes enfin
l'arrivée de monsieur rabais a stoppé le
projet donc c'est bien dommage parce que
c'est donc ça permet ça permet seulement
le chômage
je voulais conclure sinon vous aurez
individuel favorise la réussite scolaire
et notamment l'égalité des chances vous
êtes un peu plus de dix minutes de jeu
temps des paroles dix minutes 45
questions forcément il y aura une
réponse est simple
tant que parole il ya un couche il y
avait une mise en place de tablettes
numériques sur le collège de la géo par
exemple à l encours et nous on nous a
été dit que ce dispositif ne serait pas
reconduit par le département
est ce que ça a changé et moi je vous
posant la question d'avoir gagné on vous
dit que un collège va être détruit à
trappes
on vous dit que le problème mais qui
vous l'a dit comment je vous dis que non
le problème
le projet d'équipement en tablettes
numériques n'est pas abandonnée station
reposer la question excusez moi je sais
vous avez des questions à poser et c'est
bien légitime aussi disent que ces
espaces au binôme sortant j'ai réalisé
mon j'ai une précision à dire ce que
madame bouquet vous êtes très très à
cheval sur les problèmes de d'équipement
en tablettes numériques
je vous rappelle que vous étiez parents
d'élèves dans ma commune et que
lorsqu'on a commencé à équiper les
enfants tablettes numériques individuel
vous étiez là seul parent d'élève a
refusé la tablette ne soit plus un mot
je n'étais pas la seule évasion chez
elle - non je dois apparaître
me réclame est absolument pas c'est faux
6,6 faire la même chose que tout à
l'heure
plus reprendre les propos de mon
confrère noah 10 mai mais ce serait bien
voilà que mais je vais je suis né le
débat politique mais forcément mais ça
prend aussi du temps de parole des uns
et des autres voilà je vous arrête ici
et elle ira bel vous laisse un mot
rapide pour un mot rapide proposé de
nous mettre tous d'accord sur un sujet
j'aimerais les tablettes numériques pour
tous les gamins partout tout le temps
pourquoi pas dès l'école élémentaire
voire même la crèche
je pense que c'est pas bon on a des
études aujourd'hui qui nous démontre que
y compris sur le plan pédagogique
l'excès d'exposition à l'écran cause des
retards de développement cognitif des
enfants tous les enseignants dernier
glisse les exactement le téléphone
portable la télévision la tablette etc
donc attention à ce que la puissance
publique soit pas la première à dire on
met des écrans mais des écrans et c'est
ça qui va tout changer et un élément sur
lequel on peut tous être d'accord
pourquoi pas c'est de dire que et ça
concerne pas le département et ça
concerne pas les communes les
enseignants sont sous la responsabilité
de l'éducation nationale il serait bon
que si on veut déployer des outils
numériques on le fait sur la ville de
trappes contrairement à ce que vous
insinuez madame capot et vous le savez
la dameuse on essaie d'avoir une
utilisation rationnelle et cohérente de
cet outil pour nous justement qu'on dise
pas chaque enfant et votre tablette sur
votre bureau
il faut vivre matin midi et soir soit
avec la tablette soit le téléphone de
papa maman soit avec la télévision voilà
on essaye d'éviter ça et donc notamment
je souhaiterais je suis sûr que vous le
souhaiterez avec moi que le ministère de
l'éducation nationale soit capable dans
ce pays de former les enseignants à un
usage pédagogique de la tablette de
l'écran du teny du vp this qui semble
assez aujourd'hui donc c'est faux madame
6 5 ap je suis surpris que vous soyez
pas d'accord avec toi sur ce jeu se
termine par un point aujourd'hui mais si
l'on écouté la majorité donne quatre là
dessus vous devriez être plus exigeants
au contraire je suis très content et
j'espère que demain quand je serai
conseiller départemental avec kad merad
big book est où le demandera on
demandera que pierre bédier s'exprime
fortement là dessus le ministère doit
mettre davantage de moyens je n'ai pas
lâché un calcul d'enseignants et ray
eames seconde à l'isi j'ai un nombre
incalculable enseignants qui me disent
on n'utilisera pas pour l'instant les
tablettes tant qu'on n'aura pas reçu la
formation qu'on me demande depuis des
années sans l'obtenir
battons nous pour obtenir ces formations
parler du karma sexistes parlant de
l'action sociale aussi c'est l'une des
compétences si ce n'est la principale
compétence du département nicolas acquis
et le vide pour radio sensations 98,4
dans les yvelines
vous allez interroger les candidats à
propos de l'action sociale du
département les départements qui gère au
quotidien rsa retour à l'emploi aides
aux personnes âgées handicapées ou
encore la pmi protection maternelle et
infantile ces derniers mois le
département s'est aussi impliqué dans la
gestion de la crise sanitaire nicolas
c'est à vous
oui tout à fait où ils fried et puis
quelques éléments aussi de cadrage de
chypre pour bien comprendre l'importance
de l'action sociale pour les
départements dans le budget 2009
atteindre du département des yvelines
l'action sociale représente 700 43,1
millions d'euros c'est 45% du budget
donc là en fait très clairement c'est la
compétence principale du département et
il faut peut-être le dire un peu plus
aux habitants pour qu'ils s'intéressent
aussi aux élections et ses aides vous le
disiez ce soit pour les personnes âgées
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap pour l'enfance aussi en
difficulté ou pour les personnes qui
sont sans emploi
ces personnes là ce sont évidemment les
plus précaires elles vivent pour
beaucoup
le canton de trappes à la verrière et
rap on sait ce sont parmi les villes les
plus pauvres de des yvelines et la crise
du coc vide intervient là dedans parce
qu'on le sait c'est elle frappe d'abord
les plus précaires alors la question que
je souhaitais posé ce soir aux deux
binômes de candidats c est ce qu il
prévoit des mesures supplémentaires
sociale si jamais ils parvenaient au
conseil départemental où elle restait
pour pour le binôme de droite s'il
prévoit des mesures pour aider les plus
précaires aujourd'hui j'ai notamment vu
une proposition qui marquent le coup et
qui retient les esprits du côté d'al
hira bn marie boue qui s'est développée
le rsa pour les 18 25 ans je me
demandais alors s'ils peuvent le faire à
l'échelon départemental seulement de
marie bockel et un b vous avez dix
secondes de retard sur le temps de
parole
c'est à vous de commencer et de répondre
à cette question pour répondre
spontanément oui bien sûr on peut le
faire la preuve c'est que de nombreux
départements s'y engage l'art à
l'occasion de ces élections au
département de la seine saint denis qui
compte l'un des taux de pauvreté les
plus élevés de france et qui par
ailleurs est un département jeunes va
ouvrir le droit au rsa aux jeunes de 18
à 25 ans par expérimentation et peut
demander à l'état de jouer le jeu et
j'ajouterai une seconde mesure monsieur
kirilow id ce qui me semble essentiel
dans un pays comme le nôtre et surtout
dans un département aussi riche que les
yvelines il est indigne que 30% des
familles ou des personnes qui pourraient
bénéficier du rsa en soit privé
et pourtant c'est le cas parce que le
rsa doit être sollicitée en remplissant
des dossiers parfois complexes et
beaucoup de bénéficiaires potentiels
renoncent à déposer leur demande nous
pourrions très facilement parce qu'on
connaît une situation de pauvreté très
facilement automatiser le versement du
rsa
le département des yvelines pourrait
c'est une proposition que je ferai au
sein de l'assemblée départementale
demandé à l'état d' expérimenter d'être
un département pilote de la
généralisation du rsa à tous les
bénéficiaires sans qu'ils aient aller
mendier une aide sociale ça permettrait
d'ailleurs d'anticiper des situations de
vulnérabilité sociale et d'éviter que
les familles ne cèdent dans la grande
précarité
j'ai mille choses à dire sur l'action
sociale le département est
malheureusement lanterne rouge au niveau
national sur ces sujets c'est l'un des
budgets de fonctionnement les plus
faibles de france c'est le budget de
fonctionnement le plus faible de france
et sur l'action sociale
c'est l'un des départements qui met le
moins en fonctionnement ça aboutit à ce
que les salariés les propres salariés du
département ont fait grève il ya
quelques mois pour dire qu'il n'est plus
possible d'être dans une situation où on
a énormément de travailleurs sociaux qui
s'ils se démissionne qui s'en vont parce
qu'ils ne sont pas assez nombreux
savez-vous qu ici quand vous êtes dans
la difficulté sociale
c'est le cas des normes et man notamment
de deux mamans célibataires dans ma
ville vous mettez plus d'un mois avoir
un rendez vous avec l'assistante sociale
la conséquence concrète je suis sûr que
nicolas dainville vit la même chose à la
verrière c'est que les gens viennent
toquer à la porte du maire pour avoir un
bon d'urgence une aide d'urgence du ccs
du centre communal d'action sociale ont
parfois on remplace le co deux
départements qui est défaillant sur ses
missions
un mois il y a encore quelques années
c'était 15 jours d'attentes sur le champ
du handicap parfois les dossiers mettent
près d'un an à aboutir là encore est il
normal que dans les yvelines
on est trois fois plus de temps
d'attentes pour instruire un dossier à
la maison départementale des personnes
handicapées que dans le département du
bush des bouches du rhône il n'y a pas
de raison si nous étions un département
pauvre jeu pourrait le comprendre
si nous n'avions pas les moyens d'avoir
des services d'action sociale performant
je pourrais le comprendre nous sommes le
deuxième département le plus riche de
france
donc nous avons un devoir de solidarité
je passe sur la suppression des pmi dans
le département c'est un scandale
nous avions 60 pmi soixante trois pour
être précis nous avons supprimé deux
tiers des pmi dont celle de la verrière
vous avez votre permis laissée faire la
suppression de la pmi de la verrière je
crois qu'il ya des familles à la
verrière qui mérite mieux qu'un bus qui
passe une fois par semaine une fois tous
les quinze jours où par mois peut-être
même avec un centre de pmi comme celui
que vous aviez la verrière rend des
services c'est le service public et le
département des yvelines a les moyens de
fournir un service public de qualité
nicolas mainville beaucoup plus de sens
qu'elle réponde à payer 1000 peut-être
là comme ça sur sur ce point là et puis
aussi la question des délais que l'on
soit en personne en situation de
handicap ou en demandant l'aide sociale
voilà tout ce qui est excessif est
insignifiant faut faire attention à pas
être caricatural le département c'est un
département solidaire on l'a vu encore
pendant la crise près de 500 mille euros
d aide à nos commerçants à nos petits
commerçants qui allait mettre la clé
sous la porte avec les fermetures
administratives qui ont pu trouver cette
bouée de sauvetage ce n'est pas de
l'action sur une compétence y remet sur
une compétence qui n'était pas forcément
celle du département et pourtant
département répondu présent
cinq cent mille euros dead sur le 3
quand sur les trois communes du canton
les masques
au moment où on a manqué le département
d'un distribué près d'un million d'un
million de masques sur l'ensemble du
département
je pourrais parler des tests pcr je
pourrais parler des tablettes pour la
continuité pédagogique pour nos jeunes
ou pour le lien social pour nos seniors
bref pendant la crise le département a
montré sa capacité extraordinaire
d'innover pour maintenir ce lien de
solidarité
on l'a vu encore avec la vaccination où
il a joué un rôle aussi important pour
soutenir la l'intercommunalité saint
quentin en yvelines où nos communes
parfois les projets ils sont très
nombreux vous parliez du bus pmi on
pourrait parler du bus santé femmes qui
apportent aux femmes un soutien avec des
professionnels qui tourne dans nos
communes sur la pmi à la verrière
helvètes transformé en crèche et le
département va nous soutenir puissamment
dans ce projet de crèche à la verrière
avec 45 berceau ses 22 de plus donc ça
très beau projet sur lequel le
département investit le département il
avait soucis dans la rénovation des
logements c'est aussi une forme de
politique sociale que ce soit védrine
debussy on pourrait citer les lélés tous
les les logements qui sont concernés à
trappes que ce soit orly-parc à la
verrière les petits prêts à elancourt
avec des aménagements extérieurs qui
vont permettre d'offrir une qualité de
vie supérieure à nos habitants bref on a
un département qui agit qui innove qui a
envie de maintenir ce lien de solidarité
loin des caricatures qu'on peut en faire
sur la question des délais juste parce
que vous avez été interpellé sur cette
question là aussi est ce qu'il est
effectivement plus difficile plus long
d'avoir un rendez-vous un métier très
difficile je j'ose espérer qu'elle ira b
le ses assistantes sociales c'est vrai
qu'elle est elle rencontre des
difficultés il ya aussi une augmentation
de précarité avec la crise une hausse du
rsa vous parliez du rsa le rsa jeunes
vous parlez d'expérimentation mais vous
savez très bien qu'il faut que la loi
change donc ça ne changera pas j'ai trop
chaud et montana par deux
la loire parle pour la mise en place à
jaipur expérience de l'expérimentation
et deuxièmement nous on a mis en place
au niveau du département
une expérimentation qui pour le coup
marche très bien
rigal verte les brigades vertes qui
permet à des bénéficiaires du rsa d'être
orientés vers des métiers liés à
l'environnement à la verrière ces deux
parce qu'on a pu mobiliser qui s'occupe
de la propreté du flair aussi du
fleurissement
voilà c'est un contrat gagnant gagnant
des personnes qui retrouvent le pied de
l'emploi et qui permettent en même temps
d'être formés on a une aussi les
chantiers d'insertion chantier
d'insertion à la verrière ses vingt
personnes dont un certain nombre de
trappistes qui sont formés on travaille
sur la levée des freins à l'emploi des
captivity bref en terme de solidarité
c'est un département qui agit et c'est
du concret au noir et vous souhaitiez
relancer relancer le sujet ah oui une
précision peut-être sur les chiffres ont
été ont été avancées tout à l'heure
selon les données du ministère des
solidarités et de la santé le
département des yvelines consacre 432
euros par habitant pour les dépenses
sociales
c'est beaucoup moins que la moyenne
nationale qui est à 607 euros par
habitant mais ça n'en fait pas pour
autant tout à fait le dernier de vue du
classement puisqu'il ya la haute savoie
et le département de l'ain qui qui font
pire voilà c'était pour la précision est
effectivement la question qui a été
abordé à l'instant par par nicolas
dainville de l'emploi il est vrai que on
sait que cette crise ducobu d'un pèse
beaucoup sur les sur les milieux les
plus précaires et notamment les plus
jeunes qui ont des difficultés à trouver
des emplois des jobs alors est ce que
les candidats et les deux binômes ont
des propositions concrètes sur ce sujet
pour aider les plus jeunes des quartiers
difficiles qui sont déjà pénalisés
d'ordinaire l'est encore plus
aujourd'hui pour rebondir évoqué l irb
et ont une minute et même chose après on
y colle à dainville et un capuchon sur
l'emploi je pense que nous avons un
vivier très considérable d'emplois
locaux non délocalisables que nous
pourrions orienté en principalement et
nicolas d'avis la raison vers les
personnes en insertion et en particulier
aussi vers les jeunes ceux qui sont les
plus en ligne éloignés de l'emploi ce
qu'ils n'ont pas malheureusement le
niveau de diplôme qui permet de
s'insérer facilement sur le marché de
l'emploi
c'est l'économie sociale et solidaire
c'est l'économie circulaire c'est
l'économie verte
être capable de produire ici la
nourriture saine bio produites
localement que nous mettons dans
l'assiette de nos enfants être capable
de recycler nos déchets pour éviter de
continuer à en produire et à polluer la
planète et à mettre en danger notre
environnement tout cela ces viviers
doivent être explorées notamment par le
département parce que c'est la bonne
échelle tout simplement au niveau des
communes on tente on expérimente on
lance des petits projets et au niveau du
département on a un effet levier
considérable et on peut tout à fait
changer d'échelle créer des unités de
production justement de gestion des
déchets de retraitement qu'il remettra
dans le circuit des appareils comme
c'est le cas d'une entreprise par
exemple la trappe qui s'appelle envie et
qui salarient des dizaines de personnes
en insertion
nous pouvons le faire au niveau
départemental changer complètement
d'échelle pour créer des milliers
d'emplois non délocalisables garantie
pour les français du département
j'aimerais qu'on parle santé aussi parce
qu'on a un petit sujet dans ce
département en matière de santé les
yvelines son coude et zajac a parlé
aussi des infrastructures j'aimerais
bien qu'on y consacre quelques minutes
il ya beaucoup de projets sur ce sur ce
canton et qui sont aussi subventionné et
départ par lé département ce sera aussi
l'occasion anne capio nicolas mainville
si vous souhaitez répondre aussi revenir
sur la question de l'action sociale par
don hahn capshaw oui moi je veux bien
dire un mot sur le rsa qui effectivement
une compétence du groupe est du
département le gouvernement s'est
gentiment nous avons gentiment passer le
bébé de gérer le rsa et donc il ya quand
même eu une augmentation de plus de 25 %
des bénéficiaires du rsa en deux ans ce
qui est énorme c'est une dépense sans
précédent pour pour le département c'est
pour ça qu'on a créé l' agence activity
dont parlait nicolas tout à l'heure qui
est une agence pour aider les
bénéficiaires du rsa à revenir sur le
sur le thème du travail et à retrouver
du travail rapidement parce que le rsa
pour les 18 25 ans monsieur rabais c'est
bien mais sauf que le rsa ça doit pas
être une situation pérenne
c'est juste voilà on peut tous avoir
dans la vie c'est ce que dit la loi un
accident un accident de vie etc mais
hong kong je préfère qu'on aide les
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans à retrouver un
travail ou à retrouver peut-être le
chemin des études pour avoir un bagage
derrière pour mieux démarrer
plutôt que de leur verser à rsa tous les
mains voilà vous savez je ne connais
aucun jeune qui demande à ce qu'on lui
verse un rsa tous les mois ils veulent
tous travailler mais vous savez la vie
est faite de période quand on est jeunes
et des vieux on a difficile que la
solidarité soit là on peut pas nicolas
kirillovitch le confirmait être le
département qui dépense par habitant le
moins quasiment le monde et les avants
avant dernier sur son embauche il
les chiffres sur la journaliste qui a
vérifié si c'est compliqué sur le gâchis
faut avoir une agence départementale
d'insertion on innove en permanence les
chantiers d'insertion
ça marche très bien et la méridienne
assertion hausse avec un appel qui sont
à l'élevage au risque qu'ils y avait ce
rappel couvrir même temps c'est
symbolique et ceci dit ça m'arrange pour
l'égalité du temps de parole puisque
vous êtes stricte égalité et le les
chronos tombent on vous donc vous savez
les dispositifs des outils mis en place
par le département qui fonctionne et on
est et finir tout c'est la guerre des
mondes en temps réel mais tout n'est pas
nul
contrairement à ce que vous dites ou
c'est pas nous y voilà nicolas quelles
ou vite merci et faire des lieux est
pour ça qu être y faisait mois le temps
de remercier nicolas kirillovitch donc
pour radio sensation d'être intervenu
également merci à vous poursuivant le
débat il nous reste à peine un quart
d'heure démission si on peut afficher
les temps de parole un peu plus de 16
minutes pour chacun et je vous le disais
j'aimerais qu'on évoque à présent la
question des infrastructures
c'est l'une des compétences du
département il n'intervient pas seul il
finance des aménagements notamment
lorsque ça concerne elle les
déplacements les transports dans le
canton de trappes il ya énormément de
projets le carrefour de la malle me
donne qui concerne aussi des des
communes et des cantons adjacent
essentiel tout de même pour la ville de
l'avarié
l'encours il ya aussi l'enfouissement de
la nationale 10 attrape un peu plus loin
sur cet axe et à la réfection du pont de
lavilledieu également où en sont ces
différents dossiers
est ce que le départ en les départements
doit doit les accélérer et je pose la
question aux binômes sortant déjà
aujourd'hui ces différents dossiers sont
financés avance et ce sont de nombreux
travaux qui vont avoir lieu sur ce
canton
effectivement en un département qui a
investi massivement d'un département qui
investit le plus de france la rn10 de
trappes
poussé par l'ancien maire guy malandain
qui s'est beaucoup battu c'est un de ses
chevaux de bataille pour la couverture
robben aujourd'hui ça coûte près de 100
millions d'euros
le département investit près de 10
c'est très attendu est en tout cas le
département a répondu présent on
pourrait parler du pont schuller qui a
été fait qui a été doublé entre maurepas
et la verrière maintenant la priorité
c'est pour nous le pont de la ville y
aucun des points noirs de la circulation
il faut des accès piétons faut des
pistes cyclables
le tour de table est bouclée c'est près
de 30 millions d'euros c'est une énorme
attente et les travaux sont planifiés
on peut pas faire les travaux en même
temps sinon ça serait un bazar en terme
de circulation mais c'est planifié
on a beaucoup d'investissements je
pourrais parler du commissariat
d'agglomération à elancourt pour mieux
accueillir les victimes pour regrouper
près 300 policiers pour assurer une
sécurité optimisée
je pourrais parler de deux de tous ces
investissements soutenus par le
département comme les maisons de santé
le département investit beaucoup dans
nos maisons de santé et nous on n'en
pousse une sur la verrière qui est très
attendu bref on a un département qui
investit et qui est une aide incroyable
pour les communes moi c'est aussi pour
ça que je me bats avec jean michel
fourgous qui est maire d'elancourt et
c'est pour ça aussi j'imagine que le
maire de trappes
se présente c'est que le département
aujourd'hui c'est le partenaire de nos
communes pour répondre présent sur les
investissements essentiels et pour
terminer avant de laisser la parole
on a investi aussi sur la mobilité un
élan coup on a eu une très très belle
passerelle site le vélo entre plaisir et
l'encours qui permet d'améliorer je
dirais les liaisons douces on a 50 km de
pistes cyclables en plus sur ce mandat
on a voilà de très beaux ouvrages je
pourrais aussi citer la rd30 qui a été
considérablement modernisé entre plaisir
et l'encours bref de très bon
investissement pour une meilleure
qualité de vie à lire à mais je vais pas
vous dire moi là dessus que tout va pour
le mieux dans le meilleur des mondes je
trouve que cette petite musique vous
comprenez les électeurs vont se dire bon
bah si tout va bien la totalité des
cantons des yvelines sont dirigées par
la droite
on a un parti unique qui tient le
département et qui gère ces financements
alors n'allons pas voter puisque tout va
bien ça sert à rien de changer quoi que
ce soit moi je vous dis c'est une
occasion unique la d'envoyer des élus
qui seront vigilants et exigeants
parce qu un parti unique qui dirige une
assemblée c'est inquiétant ça peut être
dangereux quand on est plus contrôlée on
a tendance à dériver et vous pouvez être
certain vous pouvez être sûrs qu'ils
sont un peu avec un mari quand nous
serons dans l'assemblée départementale
nous serons vigilants et nous serons
exigeants et en particulier pour nos
trois communes
quand on voit l'état de délabrement de
nos pistes cyclables puisque vous
évoquez le sujet tous ceux qui font du
vélo à saint quentin en yvelines
au delà des trois communes du canton
savent combien c'est dangereux pour sa
propre vie de faire du vélo
savez vous que un habitant sur doute
saint-quentin-en-yvelines fait son
trajet domicile travail au sein de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
on a qui vont travailler à paris mais la
moitié travaillent dans l'agglomération
ils vivent donc nous pourrions pour 2
vraiment majorité d'entre nous prendre
notre vélo trottinette puisqu'on à
nouveau service de trottinettes pour
aller au travail c'est d'être âgées
souvent de moins d'un kilomètre 5
eh bien nous avons des infrastructures
qui nous oblige à prendre aujourd'hui
nos voitures et à polluer
faut il faut un plan de rattrapage
massif un plan vélo pour développer les
pistes cyclables pour inciter au
changement de mode de mobilité
et pour ça il faut un département qui
met le paquet nous sommes là encore l'un
des moins l'un des départements qui
investit le moins la matière
l'ille-et-vilaine par exemple a mis le
paquet elle investit aujourd'hui
davantage dans les infrastructures vélo
que dans les infrastructures routières
ça permettra vraiment de changer des
pratiques et d'inciter ceux qui
souhaitent passer aux circulations
douces non polluante à le faire nous
sommes très loin du compte si vous avez
des élus excusez moi un peu béni oui oui
qui disent tout le temps que tout va
bien qu'il faut rien changer que
l'exécutif est bien son travail
eh bien on passera après les autres si
vous avez des élus et certains le font
dans le département j'en connais des
conseillers départementaux issus de la
droite mais qui tape du poing sur la
table qui exige je les fais sur le
collège courbet et j'ai obtenu gain de
cause
mais j'attends encore des garanties
durable de long terme on est quand on se
tape du poing sur la table
on peut être entendu il vous faut donc
des élus au département qui soit capable
de ne pas dire ce que ce qu'attend le
président de l'exécutif ou les services
du département s'est pas fait il vaut
mieux et l'ire des élus courageux qui
n'ont ils sont capables de mener la
bagarre parfois pour obtenir gain de
cause
voyez plutôt que des gens qui cherchent
est les meilleurs élèves si vous êtes
élu donc les priorités sur les
infrastructures en tout cas si vous êtes
élu mais ensuite il faudra obtenir la
majorité en tous cas vos propositions
est vrai plus dans le sens dans le
transport de mobilité durable
12 pardon plutôt que des infrastructures
routières pour répondre sur ce n'est pas
que je vais vous donner un exemple qui a
été citée par nicolas mainville
franchement le pont de la villedieu le
doublement qui attendu depuis des années
des années on risque d'attendre encore
longtemps avec des versements n'ont pas
fait grand chose avec des élus qui n'ont
pas fait grand chose pour accélérer le
calendrier millions de nous pouvons
messieurs de veiller d'euros vous le
saurez regarder la rn10 et la couverture
en deux en deux mots et j'aimerais que
voilà la norville vous répondre sur ce
sont les habitants qui tous les matins
souffrent le martyre en essayant de le
traverser pour rejoindre la nationale 10
notamment nourrir 6 au risque de mourir
s'ils sont en vélo alors nicolas d'un
village indien feeling sur ce point très
précis qui est donc un des projets
d'infrastructure qui concerne ce canton
c'est le doublement de ce pont de la
ville yeux qui situe à la hauteur de la
ville de la verrière entre elles en
cours et la verrière au dessus des 10
pour être très précis alors déjà je
tiens à dire que dans la majorité
départementale
il ya une différence de sensibilité à
différentes tendances et des gens qui
sont sans étiquette des gens qui sont
plutôt de droite ya des gens qui sont
plutôt du centre bref il n'ya pas de
parti unique hégémonique on n'aurait pas
le droit de s'exprimer premier point
deuxième point élus exigent louis élus
utile c'est encore mieux et pourrait
être utile faut pas simplement vouloir
une tribune politique pour essayer de
sauver sa place trouver un mandat
peut-être non il faut être utile pour
peser dans les dossiers et peser dans
les dossiers
c'est exactement l'exemple du pont de
lavilledieu on a pesé
ça prend du temps ça prend du temps les
dossiers regarder franchement votre
prédécesseur pour les six mois terminés
s'il vous plaît votre prédécesseur
monsieur guy malandain
regardez le nombre d'années le nombre
d'années qu'il a mis pour faire accepter
pour trouver les financements près de
100 millions d'euros pour tous pour
trouver pour boucler le plan de table
avec les pour réussir avec le
département de réussir avec le
département 5001 de romandie millions
d'euros l'état du même nom non
assurables et et allez ça va terminer je
vais vous laisser moi terme est défini
dans les cévennes malirat belge laisse
captiver nicolas navy aller aux
privatisations
pierre besnard vous auriez un fort rally
rappelez vous aurez tendresse sur ab
peut être un minimum de respect sur le
temps de parole bref les le département
apporte une contribution très importante
près de 10 millions d'euros mais c'est
des projets qui prennent du temps
ces projets qui prennent du temps et le
pont de la villedieu le tour de table il
aujourd'hui bouclé ses 30 millions
d'euros la région participe le
département participe saint quentin en
yvelines participent
après ça se décide pas en un claquement
de doigts on peut pas simplement le
prenez ou le scander pour gagner
quelques voix
il ya aussi une réalité technique des
réalités travaux des réalités
financières mais on avance et on va y
arriver de commencerait en 2025
comparer la rn 10 avec le doublement du
pont de la vidéo ce n'est pas sérieux
le département il faut reconnaître cela
au président actuel a très tôt dit le
montant qu'il mettait sur la table a
joué le jeu dès le début il a même été
un promoteur de cet enfouissement guy
malandain a peiné à obtenir les
financements de l'état
mais c'est normal au contraire justement
il s'est battu mais le gouvernement lui
résister justement il n'a pas consenti
pendant des décennies d'ailleurs au delà
de 10 malandain ses prédécesseurs
bernard hugo jacquemod co n'ont pas
obtenu les financements de l'état
ça a été bouclé par guy malandain mis
dans les années 2010 en revanche sur le
son d'un vieux vous êtes conseillers
départementaux tous les deux c'est sous
votre mandature que j'ai entraînés
et donc c'est sous votre mandature il a
s'il vous plaît bruno tu es mon temps de
parole sérieusement vous avez laissé
planer les élans courtois les verrières
roi et oglo delà en ont souffert
et franchement si être conseiller
départemental être utile c'est validé la
suppression d'une pmi dans sa propre
ville alors moi j'en reste on importe
quoi n'importe quoi c'est le jour des
attaques non mais on a fini vous allez
passer vous allez avoir le temps les
hauteurs au dessus des attentes
actuelles
mais selon un analyste s'est aussi
excusé moi je vais vous laisser des
partis politiques et par interpol et les
journalistes la paye mieux la fermer ou
non mais sur je ne sais plus y'a bien
par contraintes internes à qui j'ai
demandé de ne pas parler en même temps
êtes vous arrêter là tous les dollars ce
que c'est pas du tout et je n'arrive à
l'apprendre ce débat s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît j'aimerais vous que vous
ayez le temps de conclure et qui les
téléspectateurs et auditeurs des
différentes radios partenaires et et le
temps de vous entendre aussi nous
n'aurons il nous reste quelques minutes
d'émission pas le temps d'aborder
d'autres thématiques ce soit la santé
l'environnement par exemple je propose
de l'aborder dans votre conclusion
je vous laisse à chacun puisque vous
êtes à 9 même pas neuf secondes même pas
une seconde pardon des 49 secondes
d'écart pardon mois le temps qui
s'affiche à 20 minutes 39 et 20 minutes
30 d'écart donc je vous laisse commencé
puisque c'est le tirage au sort qui l'a
décidé nicolas dainville et anne capio
et puis ce sera à vous de conclure à
l'irb et anne-marie bouquet vous avez
une minute trente
à vous de voir comment vous répartissez
la parole au sein de votre binôme
d'écouté on a une très belle équipe
composée de deux maires d'une mère
adjoint de l'ensemble de nos communes
toutes les sensibilités puisque meriam à
offrir et plutôt de sensibilité de
gauche à une cape yacht qui engagés sur
le terrain depuis de très nombreuses
années jean michel fourgous qui fait un
travail exceptionnel d'efficacité et je
pense que ces résultats ne sont plus à
ne sont plus à démontrer
on a une équipe qui veut servir
l'intérêt général et l'intérêt de trois
communes on n'est pas la recherche d'un
mandat parce qu'on aurait été condamné
ou parce qu'on aurait été invalidés on
est à la recherche
je dirais d'une efficacité d'une utilité
continuer à être utile pour défendre des
beaux projets alors vous savez on peut
toujours voir le verre à moitié vide on
peut toujours tout noircir on peut
toujours
visez jeter d'huile sur le feu et c'est
de bloquer les projets on l'a vu avec
monsieur rabhi sur le projet de l'anru à
la verrière comme si la verrière n'avait
pas le droit comme trappe d'avoir un
beau projet pour son territoire mais
nous on a envie d'être utile d'être
positif d'être je dirais rassembleur et
je pense qu'on a besoin d'être
rassembleur et quand on parlait des
enseignants nos enseignants on n'a pas
le droit aussi de les menacer on n'a pas
le droit de jeter l'huile sur le feu il
faut être calme compétents et surtout
avancer positivement je pense que c'est
ça qui est attendu par nos habitants
vous êtes arrivé à l'issue du temps
accordé pour le pour cette conclusion
c'est à vous les symbolistes vous voyez
je cherche vraiment la réconciliation
entre vos différentes listes et
anne-marie bouquet pardon moi je pense
que la démocratie c'est pas nier les
désaccords entre nous il faut assumer
que nous ne sommes pas tous d'accord
dans ce pays et proposer une offre
politique avec des options et les
électeurs tranche et à la fin on essaie
de faire du mieux possible quand on est
élu alors je ne répondrai pas aux
provocations aux anathèmes et c'est
qu'ils ont pu m'être lancé et je
resterai sur une interpellation des
électeurs vous avez raison ils ont
raison d'être frustré de douter de la
parole de leurs élus devrait la remettre
en cause et d'ailleurs je les invite à
faire davantage encore les invite même à
s'impliquer y compris en politique pour
prendre le pouvoir s'il estime que ceux
qui détiennent le pouvoir l'exercer mal
mais dans notre département en
particulier
c'est une situation unique en france
nous confions plus d'un milliard 400
millions d'euros à une assemblée
départementale ou ne fonctionnent pas la
pluralité des opinions on ne vit pas la
pluralité des opinions ou la démocratie
et de fêtes défaillante
si nous voulons avoir des élus capables
de contrôler le travail de la majorité
départementale
si nous voulons avoir des élus qui
proposent des projets innovants
notamment pour faire face à la crise
environnementale pour défendre nos
services publics pour proposer demain
une gestion publique de l'eau pour qu'on
ait un tarif unique est pas cinq tarifs
comme aujourd'hui sur l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
si on souhaite faire en sorte que la
solidarité devienne enfin ce qui devrait
être naturellement son rôle la priorité
du département
il faut avoir des élus capables
d'aiguillonner la majorité
départementale capable d'interpeller les
habitants la presse sur ce qui
dysfonctionne et de veiller au bon
fonctionnement démocratique
alors j'appelle tous les électeurs de
gauche
mais qui sont attachés à la démocratie à
se donner l'occasion de faire entrer une
vigie démocratique deux élus qui
porteront leurs paroles au sein de
l'assemblée et je vous arrête là vous
avez à 5,6 secondes d'écart pendant ce
temps de parole merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir participé c'est la fin de ce
débat du second tour donc des
départementales dans le canton la de
trappes
merci donc aux candidats pour leur
participation pour les électeurs rendez
vous à être dimanche pour aller voter et
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi sur tv
60,18 radio sensations et marmites vos
programmes se poursuivre sur nos
antennes respectives
[Musique]